if my goal is to get the customers for
10 years
then we should focus sales
to think how can they get this customer
for 10 years from the get-go our product
how to build products
some features this year some features
next year some a big new product in
three years
for that customer to get more and more
and more value to stay for 10 years
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillary stanford leap
and birthright excel let's talk about an
obsession for customer success and
there's nobody better to do it with than
zev peled chief customer officer of
appsflyer zeev knew he wanted to work in
high tech since he was 13. he got closer
and closer every summer break year after
year people gave him a chance to do more
and learn more he hopes he's paying his
debt today in his 20 plus years he
mostly worked on customer facing and he
truly loves the relationship companies
develop with their customers and the
importance of it in b2b sas
peled welcome to 20 minute leaders all
the way from the app's flyer offices how
are you
i'm good thank you for thank you for
having me thank you so much for being
here employee number seven in the
amazing apps fire one of israel's
greatest prides uh you know the go-to
tool for really any marketer in the
world and
one of the things that i'm so excited to
be speaking to you about is this new
domain that seems to have really
given room in the tech space over the
last few years and today i hear it maybe
10 times a day this idea of customer
success you're the chief customer
officer of appsflyer i don't believe
that title was a common one even
three four years ago and so ziv even
before we dig deep into customer success
and the incredible things that you've
done at appsflyer growing from two
people to 200 people on your team tell
me
about your journey how do you end up an
apps flyer and how do you learn about
yourself through different milestones in
your life
yeah so that's a great question
i started to work at itech very early so
i got my first shot uh at 13.
someone uh asked me if i can fix
speakers and i said yes i didn't know
how to fix speakers back then but i did
try and i think i was successful in that
summer fixing 20 25
uh and they were happy about that and
then
you know i think every year around the
summer break someone gave me a shot
and
uh
first of all it
i i learned so much
every year i learned 2x 4x the the year
before at some point i was researching
areas
for uh r d
just helping someone
then i did qa and then i learned so much
around many many things i think that the
best things i learned that i didn't want
to be a programmer
and then
at some point i
really understood that i want to work
with customers
i want to work
i want to understand technology i do
understand technology very deep
and but i love working with customers
and for the first
um
eight years i did work in
telecommunications
eight years after the army i worked in
and and it was
a very long relationship with the
customer and the and it was pre-customer
success era of that the relation that
relationship was i'll define it
slow very slow you know
first of all the rfa rfp
you could have lo you could have lose a
deal after two years of work and then if
you if you want it then you had two
three four years of work after that and
developing that relationship sometimes
the customers did relate to sometimes
they didn't
but customer success came from b2b sas
came when everything is connected and
customers can onboard in two weeks or
two days
and also after they onboard we know
everything about them we know their
usage we know their level of engagement
so and we know who should we engage with
who is the best
uh per person in the customary you know
always i look at four types of people in
the customer side
the value user the value of the user the
champion the decision maker and then
executive of course
and then i i think this is fascinating
because you know if even if i work now
20 years
i will not be able to and my the
development of customer success as i see
it
every year we develop it
more and more and i i said a lot in the
last month that i feel that in the last
two years i'm more of a chief strategy
officer chief technology officer of the
customer success department of the
clients services department and and i
think this is this is my true passion
today
incredible take me back to i believe it
was 2013
employee number seven apps flyer you're
joining this incredible company do you
understand the magnitude this is going
to reach within eight years
absolutely
yeah go ahead
yeah i'll i'll i'll tell you the first
thing
it's the funny part is that i had two
opportunities and i selected apps fire
that was uh
not the best compensation out of the two
and
when i joined and for the first 15 days
i didn't understand what the product
does so when i selected appsfire i truly
didn't understand what the product
is doing
and then
um i think what was fascinating about my
first six 12 months is that
for the first time in my life i saw
inbound demand
pure beautiful inbound demand
conversions
end to end from just getting the lead to
having the customer on on on and running
two days three days ten days depends how
how passionate was the customer to get
that value but everyone everyone needed
that attribution piece
and and
it was very very easy for us to deliver
that and it was beautiful in many many
areas first of all or orrin the ceo he
knew that he is hiring this the next
department is customer success he called
it customer success in the end of 2013
and he didn't hire sales for 18 months
wow we were working on leads we were
converting leads and we continued to
work with the customer
and that was
that was
so beautiful so natural
and it created a great
relationship with the
with the beginning of that portfolio
which were mainly small customers
sometimes micro
and
you know once a month twice a month
mediums but
the the amazing thing about app store is
that
a lot of those small customers grew with
us and then we became stronger and we
brought the mediums and we bought
more small and then they grew with us so
the negative churn of app star is the
negative churn of our ecosystem because
the ecosystem of the mobile app
installed marketing
incredible
and now as if i wanna i have way too
many things that i wanna that i wanna
touch on so i'm gonna move forward and i
want us to now do zoom out a little bit
and then we'll zoom back in
customer success
versus sales this new this new concept
of relationship building what does that
actually mean in its essence customer
success in in
the most tangible basic sense of the
word
yeah in in b2b
i believe that um that there's a concept
as a notion from salesforce that when
the they have a customer and the
customer grows to certain stage a
certain size they call it customer for
life
i think for b2b sauce if you are a
mission critical
product if you bring a lot of value and
customers needs you definitely on a
daily basis
you need to get to that concept you need
to think about about it in that thinking
framework
these are customers for life
and the same for the growth of those
customers sometimes those customers
start small they just need two seats now
and those two features but they will
grow to 10
and
five features and they will grow to 100
and and the entire suite i i think it's
it's really it's really important to
understand the value that the customer
needs now and to act on it
and i see a
a must
change in the world of sales so i'll be
happy to speak a little bit about it the
focus should be customer success but i
think that if you look at the company
the average b2b sas company now that is
older than five years
most of the departments think b2b is
sustaining long term
some department some departments in some
companies you'll find that they're
they're not
sales usually with
very short-term goals quotas for the
quarter
it's not b2b it's not
you know in the end we
the b2b says companies departments every
department
if optimal you should have one goal for
the company should work like this is
you you get lots of lots of lots of
small customers
and you grow them and some yield more
some yields less
but in the end you want you to yield
the 120 to 140 net dollar retention
so more tangibly for somebody who's
starting a new
company or is growing their sales team
or is rethinking now whether they're
doing it the right approach short term
versus long term what does this
translate to for the
for the ceo that has to make a decision
on how to how to now navigate their
sales team and the easiest way to
translate it
is
if my goal is to get the customer for 10
years
then we should focus sales
to think how can they get this customer
for 10 years from the get-go our product
how to build products
some features this year some features
next year some a big new product in
three years
for that customer to get more and more
and more value to stay for 10 years
right but then what is the trade-off
the trade-off is sometimes you you go a
little bit slower on the revenue
in the short term so right
think about a good salesperson
a good salesperson can sell a company
that needs
some value for x
they can sell it for 2x
but in b2b sales it translates to
a a very big potential for either
downgrades or churning the in the end of
the first year
because that customer
needed only one x for one x they only
needed that amount of value for 100 000
right
but if you sold them for 200 000 so they
might
look for something
cheaper they might look for something
alternatively they might you might just
emotionally feel
a not
very negative about that that
i bought something for 100 for 200k
but i didn't use i didn't use half of it
right so you've seen and have been a
critical factor in growing the growing
the customer success team i guess from
being the first of two employees to
se to 200
as you're growing strategically
this division
within a marketing you know company me
to be sas what is what is your strategy
so if if i were to ask now you know any
of the 200 people that are working in
customer success at apps fire what what
is the grand strategy that that ziv
employed as he was building this team
over the last eight years
yeah so i i'm i'm i'm fortunate that
four three or half years ago uh we
wrote a mission statement and we have
vision and we we are saying it all the
time we are saying it all the time
uh over and over
uh
and it's a listen learn and help
customers achieve their desired outcomes
while building long-term relationships
and it focus you on the first on the on
the two main core things that we do
we want to help customers get the value
that they bought
and if successful we want to build a
very long i also say a lot deep we want
to identify so we work in a very with a
very big customer
and hundreds of people will use our
product
all the marketers the data will flow to
other other departments but in the end
there's four
five six there's
people that we need to build a
significant relationship with
and that will help us
to understand what they achieved what
they didn't what are their kpis what are
their challenges what can we do more
because if you think about app style if
you think about my eight years in the
ten years of the company
it started with
giving
providing marketeers with a great value
for uh user acquisition two years later
we started to give value also for
re-engagement
right and then for segmentation and then
for an anti-fraud and then
so there's
over the when the company is successful
then it has a lot of opportunities to
grow can be in your building block it
could be to other building blocks i
think the more successful companies did
that in the one building block
and at some point
when they really blow up then they build
another building block i think we've
done that
pretty successfully
and and growing the team to 200 people
you know obviously today the one thing
that i hear from especially you know
every startup possible every company
hiring talent it's almost impossible um
what was your strategy there so you know
one of one of the things that i heard
you speak about previously this idea of
opportunistic hiring uh which i don't
believe it's a mainstream concept yet
but it but it probably will be
tell me about your idea of opportunistic
hiring and how that may have helped you
reach the 200 people
yeah so first of all i think that the
the success of the department is is
really hiring iran is key hiring from
the get-go uh um really
you know uh pushing the bar
uh every year
uh i think that's that's critical second
i'll i'll say that um
you you need to again in hiring you are
developing a very short
relationship for eight nine ten hours
and then both sides
needs to decide
if it's if it's a goal
so i think that this is critical so both
the candidate and the company
on nine nine hours we need to decide and
it's like it's trust from both sides
it's like you didn't see anybody i'm
telling you what is the value of upside
i'm telling you what you'll do
but
it's only about that trust
uh or from both sides
and i think that it's it's a lot about
culture so i think we were very
fortunate
to hire amazing people from the get-go
that became leaders
uh because we were successful globally
we also hired people in all
you know it's it's i think now we have
people in from 25 nationalities in 16
offices
uh so from china to san francisco and
and i think that is the the diversity of
that and understand
you know understanding of how to hire
people in san francisco versus hiring
people in beijing
it's
so different
but and i think that you know and you
can see that our
it's it's it's it's validated that our
hiring is successful because not only i
was a senior customer success manager
when i started
and grew to be the chief customer
officer
out of 50 leaders today in client
services including the customer support
team
i think uh uh
four or five were hired from the outside
as managers
the rest more customer success managers
or customer support engineers and grew
up including
all
vps uh no the only the only the new svp
that we hired from in the us now was
hired from the outside but and and and i
think that you know something that i'm
very proud of is that with more women
than men and we have more women in
leadership
and
i even believe in senior leadership in
customer success
i'm still working on that in customer
support
i i love that now this idea that i that
i hear you talk about hiring without a
specific task knowing so what i'm going
to say is opportunistic hiring you're
hiring somebody based on their based on
who they are their potential not based
on the task that you have to fulfill
tomorrow
that's something that you know i heard
you speak about that i think it's just
very inspiring and it's something that
i'm taking to heart as i'll be building
my venture is this is this something
that took place at that fire
yeah definitely you know um
when i hire csm that i need them for two
for the next two years to be a customer
success manager but it depends when when
we hired like in the beginning
so customer success were sales people
they converted customers
they were i always say and i'll say it
again they were
both routers and firewalls
so
you're a 20 people company or 30 people
company and you have four csms in the
field working with customers
getting 20 requests a week like if we
are not routers and firewalls then we
will bring all those 20 requests into
the company and then 20 30 people will
do a lot of things around those requests
so a good customer success manager has
some kind of firm firmware on their on
their router firewall and then when they
see a very important request that can be
critical also for our product for our
product development then they bring it
in
but the rest they said that they set a
good expectation with the customer
saying right
this is maybe something we'll do
early next year but we we wrote it but
and i think that the set of expectations
is also something that we
teach in and we we say a lot about
because in the end you know
sometimes people they they try to
postpone telling negative things to
customers like so
the customer waits and then gets the
negative
right
but if you
set the expectation now and you give the
negative now
at least you uh spur them the
weighting and i think it's also it
builds much more uh
a faster trust with the so they
understand like we communicate whatever
we can we can do that we will not be
able to do that
or maybe you know sometimes we are not
the platform that does
that part
right which is super important
you know i think a lot of people are
talking about aha moments or wow wow
moments in the you know in the user
journey and this is also speaking to the
b2b
b2b customers but i guess that what
you're talk what you're saying now about
setting expectations early can also save
you from the bad aha moments and the bad
surprises and you know surprises are
fantastic when they're good and they're
horrible when they're bad
and so i'm definitely taking this to
heart and ziv i really want to thank you
for coming 20 minutes go by way way too
fast and i have too many more questions
to ask you but i want to transition to
talk a little bit more about zev
and i want to take you back now to your
childhood before apps fly or before
everything
what really fascinated you as a kid as
you were just roaming the earth and
curious child what really got you going
it was absolutely tv i was truly
fascinated i could spend eight ten hours
in front of the tv and you know
sometimes these days that
people say
about screens and and kids i i love my
my kids watching screens
you need to make sure that you want to
direct the content
right uh but i think screens are great i
i i got here
through screens
right i love it and source of
inspiration today
what inspires you today as you're going
by day by day
there's many many things so i i follow
many people
uh and how they speak and and how they
think
uh it can be simon cynic can be
uh
so many books that that i listen to i i
almost not really i always i use audible
um so i think jeff bezos inspired me a
lot
you know it's it's funny that
this company upstairs a lot of the roots
of building this company oren and
lisa and russia they brought from zappos
from the book from tony shay i didn't
know tony shea until he passed away
uh but i
i know everything from that book from
the and and then i read i heard the book
uh after he passed away
and
in
speaking the book in audible i think
it's much much stronger than reading it
and and it's so many things that we've
done and so many things that we we will
do in the future
amazing remarkable
really remarkable i got a chance to
briefly meet tony in downtown las vegas
where zappos was located and it was uh
one of those experiences for a young
entrepreneur that i'm going to take with
me for a long time and i encourage
everybody to go read his book about
making customers happy and i think it's
going to be fantastic and
the last question but not least three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
uh relationship
trust
and responsiveness
relationship trust and responsiveness
and that reminds me that we didn't even
get to touch on your obsession now to
building relationships as a key strategy
and so we're going to be saving this for
another episode but ziv thank you for
the for the wonderful time uh
congratulations on on amazing amazing
things with appsflyer really one of the
biggest prides that we have here in in
the ecosystem and one of the most
amazing companies in the world and and
looking back at these eight years and
starting to understand your personal
strategy and apps flyer strategy
through its customer relationships i
think that's remarkable and i'm to take
a lot of lessons with me for my own
ventures so thank you very much and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you for having me
of course
[Music]